let's now take a look at the flavor of
what's going on in some congressional
races among republicans and i will tell
you it is absolutely sick
last night
republicans debated
in the new hampshire first district
uh
in the new hampshire first district race
there were five republicans up on the
stage
four of them said they would impeach joe
biden on day one
what
impeach him for what well that they
don't agree on you really have to see
this and this is really indicative of
the brazen
partisan unhinged nature of the
republican party at this point in time
you are going to hear in a moment from
tim baxter
caroline levitt
russell prescott and gail huff brown
all of whom are ready to impeach joe
biden the day they get into congress if
they do
now the fifth republican here matt
mowers
he's not ready to say impeach yet but he
certainly thinks we need hearings to
figure out whether to impeach joe biden
i know it's extraordinarily disturbing
it's extraordinarily sad let's take a
listen would you vote to impeach
president biden for anything he's done
so far in office absolutely
yes the dereliction of duty at our
southern border he's allowed for an
invasion of our country
now remember
almost nothing has changed at the
southern border
from trump to biden other than as the
pandemic eased
more people started to try to come to
the united states
there has been and some families have
been reunited that were separated under
trump there has been no
real change but these republicans want
you to think there's been some 180 at
the border trade his oath of the
constitution and our homeland is brown
the commander-in-chief has one job to
protect americans at home and abroad and
he did not protect americans in
afghanistan that was the day i got into
the race so remember that the
they don't know they're not sure why
they don't agree on why
but they know biden needs to be
impeached one it's because of what he
did at the southern border oh well
actually no it's because of what he did
in afghanistan which by the way is the
same thing trump would have done right
that's three for three councillor
prescott yes i would four for four and
matt murray we do have to have hearings
to look into these things the fact that
you have the president and secretary of
defense lying to the american people
about intelligence reports coming out of
afghanistan has to be looked into would
you so four out of five say yes i would
impeach on day one i would vote to
impeach now
and number five out of five says
i've got to do hearings we must do
hearings in order to figure out whether
to impeach
oh boy so it's the border it's their
election of duty it's afghanistan or
it's just not really clear why
understand that we have an economy right
now that is essentially at full
employment we have consumer demand for
all sorts of products and services off
the charts demand for doctors is off the
charts demand for electricians is off
the charts demand for plumbers is off
the charts demand for car detailing is
off the charts
uh we are out of afghanistan
which trump was going to do two jobs
reports in a row with significantly
greater than expected jobs numbers gas
declining 26 percent over a two two and
a half month period as rapid a decline
as we have ever seen in gas prices
inflation coming down with an inflation
report coming out tuesday which i expect
is going to be uh pretty pretty good um
inflation reduction act a packed act i
could go on and on and on
and the absolute political theater
taking place among the republican party
has four out of five republicans
outright saying i would impeach him
right now and a fifth saying well we
should at least look into it with some
peerings and the most important takeaway
here is you know there's the optics of
the cartoonish nature of this and that
is not something to be ignored it is
cartoonish and it's a joke
but there's a bigger story here that is
a broader republican story
what is the policy vision for the
republican party that they've
articulated i would ask over the last
six months
over the last two years over the last
six years increasingly there is no
policy
it's we've got to stop
marxism
we've got to stop woke
we've got to impeach biden it's
dereliction of duty
there the country is going to hell it's
donald trump you'll hear him on indian
tv this is going to be a rare treat for
you on indian tv donald trump saying the
country is going to hell
and it's all about appeasing the most
extreme unhinged elements of their party
and i want to remind people the new
hampshire first district in fact i want
to be accurate about this new hampshire
first district
2020 presidential results
um
in the new hampshire first congressional
district
in 2020
this was a
uh
trump won it in 2016
but then biden won it quite easily yeah
biden won it by six in 2020. this is not
like an extreme district now these are
republicans i understand the republicans
there may be extreme this is a this is a
district that voted biden pretty handily
for what's considered a purple state new
hampshire in 2020
and yet they are still kowtowing to the
most extreme elements of the republican
party will that work in the general i
mean probably not
but it is political theater all meant to
appease their dear orange leader and
it's pathetic i want to remind you that
on 9 19
we are doing a 19 themed membership
special if you've been thinking well
david i kind of like the show i like the
idea of the bonus show regardless of
what alex jones says oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad right if that has tickled your
fancy but you're just waiting for the
right moment to strike get on my mailing
list at davidpakman.com
and on 9 19
you'll get a beautiful email a perfect
email telling you how to avail yourself
of an extraordinary membership discount
we'll take a quick break and be right
back